[Music]
sony pictures lifted the review embargo
for its highly anticipated anti-hero
flick
venom on tuesday october 2nd ahead of
its october 5th release date granting
permission to the fortunate few who saw
the film at its world premiere in los
angeles to post their spoiler-free
thought
in other words the reviews are in and
they're weird
bottom line many critics thought it was
hilarious but not quite on purpose
and that it features an unwelcome
throwback feel as if the mcu comic book
movie renaissance never happened the
hollywood reporters todd mccarthy for
example
thinks that venom is more black sheep
than black panther
writing venom feels like a throwback a
poor second cousin to the all-stars that
have reliably dominated the box office
charts for most of the century
there's a silver lining however tom
hardy collider's perry nimrod found
hardy typically charming as eddie brock
but wished the film had more of an
edge writing significant chunks of venom
don't work at all but there is some
serious charm to the eddie venom
relationship not sure i had the intended
reactions to some scenes but
fun is fun even when it's totally
ridiculous right it's too bad they
didn't go for the r rating though
nerdist hector navarro felt much the
same but pointed out that the film kept
true to the source material and
portraying eddie as a guy with an
off-kilter sense of humor
writing despite some problems venom did
right by its main character
people forget that he's always had a
weird sense of humor in the comics and
that humor is fully on display in the
movie
the verge's brian bishop wrote that
hardy gave a fully fleshed out
capital p performance as venom writing
hardy is always watchable no matter the
role but there's so much to take in here
that it almost feels like he's putting
on a one-man show
echoing that sentiment uprock's senior
entertainment writer mike ryan said he
was quote
fascinated with venom mostly because
while the rest of the cast was in a dark
superhero movie
hardy was decidedly not ryan tweeted
hardy is basically remaking jim carrey's
liar liar i kind of loved watching this
movie in a rocky horror type of way
oh i have a parasite yeah
my name is chen one of the harshest
reactions to venom came from ign's tom
jorgensen who wrote
sorry to say that venom is pretty much a
complete failure a tonal mess that feels
15 years old ignoring the storytelling
strides that the superhero genre has
made in recent years
mcu cosmic's jeremy conrad kept his
critique simple but
biting sharing a tweet that references
part of a line venom snarls in one of
the film's trailers
freelance comics journalist meg downey
delivered perhaps the most
interesting response to venom calling it
an excruciatingly surreal experience and
likening it to ben
affleck's daredevil english hulk and
halle berry's catwoman not
exactly great company downey wrote in
one tweet the humor the story beats
everything right down to the eminem
theme song
feels like it emerged kimmy schmidt
style from a sealed off early aughts
bunker
all in all the reviews indicate that
viewer mileage will vary wildly with
venom putting it just ahead of other
franchises non-starters like the
disastrous universal outing of the mummy
but owen gleberman a variety thinks it
might not be enough
this gateway into the sony universe of
marvel characters may not sputter as
badly as tom cruise is the mummy but it
could turn out to be a similar case of a
franchise kickoff that doesn't fully
attain franchise liftoff but if it does
well enough at the box office the
planned venom trilogy could indeed
become a reality
and all signs indicate the franchise is
primed to improve with each installment
leading up to fingers crossed a
potential spider-man crossover
or at least a substantial appearance by
venom's rival carnage if
and spoiler alert those early reports
about the mid-credits scene prove
correct
make your own call october 5th when
venom hits theaters nationwide